Though he's an intergalactic tyrant to whom
Earth is just one planet among millions, Thanos
had a strangely human experience in Avengers:
Infinity War.
Somehow, the Mad Titan instantly recognized
Tony Stark as the Armored Avenger Iron Man
when the pair brawled on the planet Titan.
So how exactly did Thanos know who Tony was?
In the commentary track on the Avengers: Infinity
War digital release, director Joe Russo revealed
that Thanos recognized Tony as the person
who foiled his scheme to seize power over
Earth through Loki in 2012's The Avengers.
Russo explained:
"He's aware of Stark from the original Battle
of New York as the person who undid the plan."
"YEAH!"
Essentially, the purple-faced Titan knew who
Tony was in Infinity War for the same reason
Tony predicted that an enormous threat was
coming to Earth in The Avengers: they are
both, as Thanos says in the film, "cursed
with knowledge."
As Russo noted, this results in a "sort of
existential connection" between Thanos and
Tony.
While Tony spent years pouring blood, sweat,
and tears into upgrading his armor to nanotech
levels and keeping a close eye on what lies
ahead, Thanos did the same in devising a plan
to wipe out half the universe's population
in order to clear a path for a "better" future.
When the two have been on their own, their
plans have gone relatively smoothly.
It's only when the two face off - indirectly
in The Avengers and directly in Infinity War
- that each derail the other's forward momentum.
Russo went on to explain:
"The journey that Tony's been on as a genius
scientist is [...] the evolution of his armor.
This is the best it's ever gonna get for Tony.
He goes to the cutting edge of what his mind
can deliver, and it still is not enough to
beat Thanos.
In fact, it barely keeps him in the fight."
Infinity War co-screenwriter Christopher Markus
also pointed out the major similarity between
the Mad Titan and the genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist: both of them have concrete
visions regarding what a perfect future would
look like, despite holding wildly different
ideas about how to reach that end goal.
"I see a suit of armor around the world … That
sounds like a cold world Tony … I've seen
colder."
"And I will bathe the starways in your blood."
So yeah - they have slightly different plans
in mind.
Still, Markus elaborated on their connection,
saying:
"You realize this interesting parallel between
Thanos and Tony.
They're both aware of something from an early
point and constantly having to deal with being
smarter.
Thanos is a futurist as much as Tony Stark."
Although Infinity War didn't address Thanos'
link to Tony beyond the mention that they
both bear the burden of wisdom, this actually
isn't the first time Russo has discussed the
pair's connection.
Speaking with The Telegraph India ahead of
the film's release, the director mentioned
that "all the heroes" in the movie are Thanos'
enemy, but the Mad Titan has "the most specific
connection to Tony" because they both have
plans for the world.
"He's a futurist but a brilliant futurist
so he understands where the world is going."
Getting down to brass tacks, Thanos and Tony
have a heck of a lot more in common than one
might assume - and the Mad Titan even apparently
holds Tony in high esteem, telling him that
he has his respect near the end of Infinity
War.
But this doesn't necessarily mean that we
can view Thanos and Tony as fundamentally
the same.
After all, one is a galactic warlord who commits
genocide on a universal scale, and the other
is an ex-military weapons manufacturer working
hard to protect people.
So despite their similarities, don't expect
them to be sitting down for shawarma anytime
soon.